Speaker 1: Let's talk a little more about this
loyalty pledge that Republicans and the Republican
National Committee want. Every candidate who
is vying for the Republican primary to sign
in advance of participating in any debates.
We talked about this last week. Many of you
wrote to me about it and we have more about
it. I'll remind you what's going on. The RNC
and the Republican Party want every single
candidate who's running to agree in advance.
Even if I lose, I will support whoever is
eventually the Republican nominee. Really,
the concern here is Trump. Why? Well, Trump is
a child and Trump puts himself above everything,
above party, above everything. And so it's a
legitimate risk to the Republican Party that Trump
might run in the Republican primary, but lose.
Maybe DeSantis wins. Maybe. Who knows? Somebody
else wins. And then Trump, instead of saying,
Hey, you know what, I lost fair and square,
I'm going to support the person that won. I mean,
it's like laughable that he would do that, right.
Trump instead will say, well, you know what? It
was stolen. It was rigged, and I'm going to run
as an independent and show these Republicans
whose boss and the reason that this would be
so devastating to the party is there are so
many states where the margins are always thin,
whether it's a Republican or a Democrat who
wins everything from Florida, Pennsylvania,
Ohio, Michigan, Wisconsin, Arizona. There's
so many states where it's always pretty close.
If Trump ran as an independent and took just 5 to
7% of the Republican vote, it would guarantee that
the Democratic candidate wins. Trump, running
as an independent, could guarantee one of the
biggest Democratic victories in 2024 that we've
seen in decades. So they've asked him to sign a
loyalty pledge. They're asking everybody to sign
a loyalty pledge. And one of the things that came
up last week was Trump isn't going to do this.
But now there's a different perspective. Now,
the perspective for many of you is, oh, Trump
will do it. He just won't abide by it. Well,
on CNN, Ronna McDaniel was asked by
Dana Bash about this entire loyalty
pledge scenario. And here's what she had to say.
Speaker 2: I want you to listen to what former
President Donald Trump said a couple of weeks ago
in an interview with conservative radio host Hugh
Hewitt on this very topic.
Speaker 1: Please.
Speaker 3: If you're not the nominee, will
you support whoever the GOP nominee is?
It would depend I would I would give you the same
answer I gave in 2016 during the debates. It would
have to depend on who the nominee was.
Speaker 2: So are you prepared to
block the former president in 2016?
Speaker 4: I did. Everybody signed it in 2016.
Speaker 2: But this is about the here
and now. You didn't commit to it.
Speaker 4: I think they're all going to sign it.
I really do. I think the voters are very intent
on winning and they do not want to see a debate
stage of people saying, I'm not going to support
this guy. I'm not going to support this guy. What
they need to say is I'm going to do everything
I can to defeat Joe Biden. And that means
supporting the nominee of the Republican Party.
Speaker 2: You can't see a scenario where
Donald Trump would just skip the debate
if he's forced to sign something saying, I.
Speaker 4: Want to be on the debate stage.
I think President Trump would like to
be on the debate stage. That's what he
likes to do, and I expect they'll all be there.
Speaker 1: So, listen, I actually have revised my
view a little bit. Last week, I was really leaning
towards Trump's never going to sign this thing,
and they will capitulate and let him on the stage
because otherwise their voters will, you know,
start a mutiny. I actually now believe the more
likely scenario is Trump will sign whatever he
needs to sign it to get to the debate stage. He'll
play coy if and when the question comes up during
the debates. But then if he loses, he'll say screw
that pledge. It's not legally binding. It means
nothing. I signed it, but then when I signed it,
I meant if they if they fairly win, they didn't
fairly defeat me. So I'm going to go and run as
an independent anyway, if that's what he wants to
do. The point is, Trump's completely dishonest
in this way. And the more I think about it,
I can't think of any anyone who knows Trump at all
the way we do because we've been following him for
so long. Who thinks he would actually come out and
just say, I am going to support this person that
just defeated me? It's very difficult to imagine
that that's the case. The Interview had another
interesting moment, which was about accepting the
results of 2024. And Ronna McDaniel also plays coy
with us. She goes, Oh, yeah, no, I think all the
candidates will accept the 2024 results because
we're going to win, which is exactly the language
that got us into the 2020 mess to begin with.
Speaker 2: Mean, we're talking about promises
now that whomever the Republican nominee is.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Ultimately
we'll accept the results in 2024.
Speaker 4: I expect that they will
accept the results in 2024. I'm not I don't
know who that person is right now. But yes,
we're going to accept the results and we're
going to move forward and work to govern this
country. But I think they're going to accept the
results because they're going to be the president.
Speaker 1: Well, that doesn't really inspire
confidence. Right. Saying they will accept
it either way is different than there is
going to be no reason not to accept it
because the Republican candidate will have
won. So, listen, it's not a big surprise,
but they are already gearing up for the same
election denying nonsense in 2024. Let's not
get ahead of ourselves on that. There's time to
get to that. But just know they are setting it up.